[Music]
fire is an interesting word it always
comes up in freedom of speech
discussions I am true a brand from the
long now foundation this might be a nice
occasion for a little call-and-response
I'll call out a question and you shout
back to the one word response what's the
word you're not allowed to shout in a
crowded theater another what's the word
and not allowed to shout in a crowded
theater one last one what's the word
you're not allowed to shout at a crowded
theater huh I just think we set a new
record in freedom of speech it might be
a new low who knows more about fire than
anyone is our speaker Stephen pine well
good evening and thank you for coming
and thanks to the long now foundation
for allowing me to come and speak today
this evening about fire in all of its
forms this will be a rapid a rapid
survey perhaps the historical equivalent
of a planetary flyby will cover a lot of
ground a lot of history so fasten your
seatbelts phasers on stun and we'll go I
got interested in fire engaged with fire
first
shortly after I turned 18 and signed on
as a smoke chaser at the North Rim of
Grand Canyon
I returned for 15 seasons and all and
became a PI romantic not a pyromaniac
important distinction well on a fire
crew you quickly learn how a fire shape
a season and how fire seasons can shape
a life and I wondered if the same might
be true for Humanity after all we are
uniquely fire creatures
a uniquely fire planet so eventually I
traded in my Pulaski for a pencil became
a scholar on fire and tonight I'll give
you the short short version of what I've
learned well among the ancient elements
fire is the odd man out
earth air water all our substances but
fire is a reaction it synthesizes its
surroundings it takes its character from
its context so it may be nature's first
experiment in post-modernism but fire is
a shapeshifter and that has been that
has proved true intellectually as well
the other ancient elements all have
academic disciplines devoted to their
study even whole departments but the
only fire department on the University
campus is the one that sends emergency
vehicles when an alarm sounds I think
the best way to think about fire is to
realize that it's a product of the
living world fire on earth exists
because of life on Earth life created
the oxygen life created and rearranges
and organizes the fuels and as soon as
life began colonizing the continents it
began to burn and it's burned ever since
we have fossil charcoal that dates back
420 million years you can find fire
scars in trees in the Petrified Forest
but fire burn patchily different places
burn in different ways different eras
burn with different intensity so as life
changes as the atmosphere changes so
fires change so quickly if we go back
we're starting to reconstruct some of
the paleo history of fire first evidence
of fire as plants began to diversify
oxygen is still relatively low not so
many fires plants increase oxygen
increases lots of fires and then an
overwhelming amount of fire and that
only ends with an extinction event
because the stuff that makes fire
possible disappeared so fire
disappears with it or changes its
character or if we were to put a grande
scroll across it we'd see IRA's with
high fires
IRA's with low fires current fire world
has been whipsawed between fire and ice
glacial and interglacial although
there's plenty of evidence now that
where we are in a new era
even the geologically significant e are
driven by ourselves and I would argue
driven by our capacity over fire so for
most of history natural history fire in
the form of fast combustion has competed
with slow combustion that is metabolism
respiration decomposition in the organic
world they tend to compete and when this
really becomes this is a very difficult
problem to sort out it's really fire
Ecology's three-body problem there's no
exact solution everything is always a
little bit out of sync this has gone on
for a long time what underlies it
patterns of wetting and drying it has to
be wet enough to grow stuff then dry
enough to burn so in Arizona where I
come from we have wet winters the
deserts burn if we have dry winters the
mountains burn in the summer otherwise
you would depend on an ignition source
which is almost always lightning
overwhelmingly lightning and that is
pretty much a kind of lottery or it was
until the creature arrives who could
wrest control away from lightning in
effect seize control over ignition this
is a real phase change in the natural
history of the planet this is a real
marker in human history as well because
people can now begin rearranging
redistributing redefining the domain of
fire increasing it in effect making a
pact with fire that will expand fires
domain at the same time fire will
empower humans in a huge way we got
small guts and big heads because we
learned to cook food we went to the top
of the food chain because we learned to
cook landscapes and now we've become a
geologic presence because
we're cooking the planet we have become
have been for a long time it
increasingly with increasing authority
been the keystone species for fire on
the planet directly and indirectly you
know other creatures knock over trees
and dig holes in the ground
hot eat plants we do fire our
environmental power our ecological
signature and in many ways our our
environmental presence is really a fire
power and as we've learned to expand it
our own presence on the planet is
increased so fire has long been the
focus of social life the hearth what
could be long the definition of a family
those who shared a hearth around fires
we worked we made things we played we
worshipped round fires we told the
stories about who we were who we are how
we've come to be focused by the way for
the linguists in the in the crowd focus
is the Latin word for hearth literally
the focus of human life fire was very
likely our first domestication think
about the terms particularly in English
we use to describe how we tend feed care
for fire the things you have to do in
effect the Domus was made to protect the
fire more than the people it's certainly
a catalyst for technology very little of
technology and the further back in time
you go the more powerful this is this is
the case does not rely on fire somewhere
as an all-purpose catalyst to speed up
and make possible we can transform mud
into bricks and into glass or into
metals how much of our technology relies
on fire our chemistry even our
philosophers pairing them through fire
fire was the means that you transmuted
things made the dross world into a
knowable world and indeed a habitable
world and because of its presence it's a
to empower us I think fire may very well
also be our first Faustian bargain
something that we're still having to
deal with
well fire tended to occupy two forms one
was a closed one in a built environment
in a in a Domus or some kind of Forge or
confined place and then fire in the
landscape and for the most part these
two played equally out but in time the
two will come to interact in curious
ways aboriginal fire was a very powerful
one by aboriginal fire I mean that fire
economy which is based on the ability to
determine the place and time of ignition
it's very powerful in places that
already have fire you can take over that
landscape very quickly by changing the
timing of the fire by preemptively
burning by altering the way it appears
but it's very difficult to introduce
fire where it where the environment is
not going to tolerate it the power of
landscape fire resides in the power to
propagate and that does that is not
something under people's control except
to the extent that they can control
where and when they burn so if you want
more power if you want to increase your
ability to manipulate the world through
fire you're going to have to change that
environment so you're going to start
slashing and drying you're going to
drain you're going to introduce
livestock in other other ways to churn
up the landscape to put it into a form
that will make it more amenable to
burning so that now you can begin
burning where nature would never have
burned and you can begin burning in ways
and times that wouldn't have been
possible but this too comes with limits
you know it's limited by the ability of
that particular ecosystem to grow fuels
in a quote sustainable way if you overdo
it the system begins winding down or
what Linnaeus and others called leaves a
world of rich parents and poor children
so if you want to increase your your
fire power and it seems a large number
of us always do
you'll have to find another source of
things to burn and we have an endless
search around the countryside for stuff
so we can move our farms and pastures
through forests through the landscape or
we can rotate the landscape through a
continued
you know and European agronomists have
always hated fallow
they've detested it for at least a
couple thousand years they have
denounced it in literature it's a waste
a waste of land that needs to be put
into production and worse its burned you
know I think well maybe if you look at
this as a fire historian and you realize
that almost all agriculture outside of
flood plains where water can take the
place of fire for fertilizing and
fumigating almost all those places need
fire maybe they got it backwards maybe
it's not burned to get rid of it maybe
it's grown in order to be burned because
at some point you're going to need that
ecological jolt that kind of biotic
defibrillation that fire provides but
nonetheless you can run out there are
crazy stories people even bringing
seaweed and drying it out to get more
stuff to put on the landscape so they
can get the proper fire so eventually we
turned to lithic landscapes we found
another source of things to burn and we
began burning them in different ways on
a huge scale this again is another phase
change in the history of fire and I I
think in the history of the planet we
began putting them into machines burning
them into various appliances applying
that our fire power indirectly but also
multiplying it so here's Matthew Boulton
of James Watts business partner
remarking here's what we sell sir we
sell what all the world desires to have
power so as we begin industrializing
these two kinds of fires burning surface
biomass
and burning fossil biomass begin to
cross one another mostly in the 19th
century particularly in the late 19th
century with very interesting and
sometimes very exotic results I think of
this transition I like to call it the
pirate transition and I do so by analogy
to the better known demographic
transition in human populations in this
case we're talking about a population of
fire it explodes many more sources
landscape is being churned up lots more
stuff to burn lots of abusive burning
reckless burning promiscuous burning and
then after the new order begins to take
hold all the older fires begin
disappearing and you you're left below
replacement values so we're not able to
reproduce the fires that the ecosystem
needed before how do we do well operates
by substituting virus technologies use
electricity instead of open flame we
actively suppress fires open flame is
pretty much forbidden becoming even more
so and built landscapes and we change
how we live in the land where we where
we needed fire previously we find
surrogates for it we begin putting
houses into formerly rural landscapes
industrial societies love to create
nature reserves parks wilderness
preserves of one kind all this changes
the way fire is going to appear in the
land because the keystone species has
changed how it does business so we
substitute for power many forms of now
indirect but we also use that new
mechanical power to actively fight fires
and take it out of the landscape so
we're left with it with a curious case
that in much of the developing world
there's an overabundance of bad fires
and much of the developed world there's
a deficit of good fighters
but the same thing happens
intellectually at roughly the same time
very curious at the same time fire
begins being being confined being put
into some kind of appliances being taken
out of the landscape being taken out of
houses in factories out of sight out of
mind
it starts disappearing from intellectual
history as well since ancient times fire
had been recognized as a fundamental
property
Heraclitus famously said that all things
are in exchange for fire and fire for
all things well it was known as
Heraclitus the dark with good reason but
even in Aristotelian physics fire was
the model system you had to explain
change in the world and if you couldn't
explain fire you couldn't do it but by
as the Enlightenment settles in
particularly after the discovery of
oxygen and oxygenation
as a as a Kim as a primary chemical
reaction fire goes from being a
fundamental phenomenon even an informing
principle into a subset it disappears
into oxidation chemistry disappears into
thermodynamics electromagnetism
physiology the question of animal heat
which had always been thought of as a
kind of fire this now becomes a fire
disappears it's no longer discussed as
an organizing presence it becomes a
subset of the more fundamental
disciplines which is the situation we
still have today this conversion most of
us I'm sure in this room are aware of
some of the consequences for the
atmosphere but this conversion has
cascaded throughout the planet and is
affecting all forms in the past the
human problem with fire had been
primarily to search for new sources to
find new stuff to burn there was never
enough until until fairly recently
now it's essentially unbounded it's not
infinite but we keep finding new stuff
to burn
and we can burn a whole lot more than is
good for us and the problem has become
one of sinks what to do with all the
effluent from the stuff we're burning
it's also I think marking a change it
will have to mark a change in how we
understand the Earth's system and the
role of fire in it because for a long
long time fire had been seen as a subset
of natural history particularly of
climate history but increasingly I think
we have to make we have to realize that
natural history the Earth's system and
even climate history are becoming
subsets of fire history in fact I would
suggest we could rename the Anthropocene
if you wish does the pyro seem because
fire fire is the driving power that
allows us to make the kinds of changes
we've been making and I suggest it not
simply as an alternative we're not
simply in an interglacial but fire
itself may now have the informing
presence imposing itself on the planet
in the way that I said earlier well
we'll see you know these are great
photos earth at night you've all seen
them if you're interested in fire you
quickly realize there were two sources
of light here so we have Western Europe
ablaze with lights but not all those
lights are the result of industrial
combustion there are other sources but
you can bet that kind of combustion is
somewhere in the chain of their creation
and all of them are substituting for
open flame sub-sahara africa wash with
flame there are a few places where
lights dominate and this is this seems
to be the case
they don't coexist they don't play well
with each other you have one or the
other and you have some transition
period between them there are some
extreme cases I'm sure many of you have
seen photos like this these have been
around for a long time this is a more
recent one North Korea conspicuous by
the absence of light at night but if you
look at the motifs imagery of hot spots
during the day
you see exactly the opposite so here
very little environmental difference no
cultural difference a human event of war
60 years ago has caused a change in
these two yeah we often hear in the fire
community if you're familiar with the
fire community or a member of it or deal
with them you'll often hear the
expression hey fire knows no borders oh
really
it seems to me here pretty well respects
the DMZ this transition as I suggested
it's a time of of extensive even abusive
burning these are all from the 19th
century early 20th century United States
the u.s. at the time was much like
Brazil in recent years basically in
agricultural society rapidly
industrializing undergoing this
transition landscape clearing railroads
this was the trans amazon highway of its
day going into michigan lots of wreckage
the one of the upper rights my favor
these are coastal redwoods in California
converted to dairy farms so it didn't
take a lot to realize that something's
amiss here but as I suggested you we go
from this this situation these
circumstances almost a fire orgy and
after the new order is established we
end up with a fire famine and we'll see
how that plays out in a minute but that
kind of wreckage lives lost cities new
town's overrun landscapes natural
resources destroyed did not go unnoticed
and all progressive thinkers of the day
decided something would have to
intervene to stop this ruination by axe
and fire and that would have to be the
state and so we see as a global project
the emergence of state-sponsored
conservation with fire very much a part
of that seem really animating in giving
urgency to these arguments the first
professional Forester in the u.s.
actually can't emigrated from
rusha Bernard Ferno he looked over the
scene and he dismissed it as one of bad
habits and loose morals said the
civilized country would never tolerate
this so we took the steps the civilized
country should take we intervened to end
it and we were not alone but the task
importantly was given to foresters it
didn't have to be it was given to a
group that emerged at a central Europe
that is temperate Europe an odd part of
the world because climatically you don't
have what dry periods precipitation is
more or less constant there's no natural
basis for fire there's no dry lightning
so the only fires you see in this
environment are fires that people put in
so it was seen as a human problem solely
no ecological basis for fire no
justification for it forestry becomes
the Oracle and in a sense the
engineering core for free burning fire
because fire has disappeared out of
academic circles at this point so the
study of fire is now given over to a
group which fundamentally due Tessa and
is dedicated to its extirpation and that
will have consequences as I say this was
a global project it was pursued in the
Northern Rockies and the central
provinces of India there in the upper on
the upper right hilltop Forester in
India under the British regime there he
is looking for fires big drum goes down
beats the drum out the message so the
local villagers will come help him put
it out
well the villagers were the ones who and
all likelihood said it with to their
mind good cause so they were not in the
least interested nonetheless this was
this was a major undertaking by British
India any of you fans of the of
Kipling's jungle books ever wonder what
happened to Mowgli after he goes to the
man village and grows up
well kipping wrote a story a sequel that
describes what happens Mowgli joins the
Indian forest service
it becomes a fire guard and he fights
against poaching and jungle fires and I
like that because uh sort of loony as it
seems it shows the depth and the
pervasiveness of these ideas among
thinkers of the day so the Great
Architect of the British system in India
Dietrich Brandis a German botanist
turned Forester administrative genius
set it up and one of the major ways they
decided to handle the problem was to
create forest reserves then there were
some special attention reserves we would
consider parks today and that's sort of
the build up of this so it took several
forms but this was the primary one and
by this they could break the cycle of
abuse that's the growth of national
forests and equivalent public lands in
the United States it's going on at the
same time Gifford Pinchot the first
chief of the Forest Service beginning in
1905 studied under Brandes his successor
studied under Brandes went to India they
wanted to adapt that system bring it to
the US Pinchot said he hoped to achieve
some little bit in this country of what
Brandis had achieved in India it's a
remarkable statement he later he later
thought that we had a lot to learn from
the French in Algeria other than getting
out I don't know what that would be but
nonetheless this was the same model that
was applied we created public domains
from colonized lands now that larger
fire story I've been telling you is the
one we share with the rest of the planet
this story of creating a kind of public
land or crown land out of colonized
countries is when we share with those
countries that have very similar fire
problems to ours who are they well
Australia Canada Russia they all have a
similar history of land tenure and the
creation of Forest Institute forestry
institutions to manage them and so forth
but the paradox here is that they
created these reserves to protect them
from all the fires outside and instead
what they wound up doing was creating a
permanent habitat for free burning fire
within because these were not going to
be subject to this pirate transition
that would happen outside it so why do
the major fire powers today have
extensive wildland fires because they
have extensive wild lands and that is a
historic artifact and in all these cases
wherever France Britain Netherlands us
else went they created same kind of
programs to eliminate fire from the
landscape as fully as possible often by
a kind of paramilitary model so we we
spiraled the big starry fire secondary
story those countries that have all
these wildland fire problems let's spend
a few minutes talking about the u.s.
I'll be fairly brief but I think we can
we can break down our national story in
a way that that makes sense within this
larger there so it's a kind of nested
narrative within the backdrop are all
these wild abusive I mean hundreds of
people are being killed throughout the
American West around the Great Lakes
other settlement areas that's the
backdrop u.s. Forest Service is created
given national reserves 1905 that's
really the beginning of the modern story
nineteen note 1910 they were hit with a
wave of fires the famous big blowup
traumatized the agency it was a kind of
long march for those young foresters and
they would never forget it they would
never allow a fire like that again to
happen on their watch and it wasn't
until that entire generation is gone the
next three chief foresters of the Forest
Service were all personally on the fire
lines in the Northern Rockies during the
big blowup they lost seventy eight
firefighters six different incidents all
in one afternoon evening million dollars
over budget that was
real money in 1910 the agency could have
been bankrupt and defunct but that
brought together a pattern and that has
stayed with us through the century so
for the next 50 years borrow a little
ecological language here we adopted the
kind of resistance model we would not
allow fire to become a threat and the
way to stop it was to attack every fire
while it was small every fire could be
controlled when it started so you did
everything you could to get there as
quickly as you could put out all fires
and it turns out if you take people out
of these landscapes and a lot of these
places lightning lightning fills in very
nicely so you haven't eliminated fires
the big boost comes in the 1930s with
the Civilian Conservation Corps in
effect a civilian army that could be put
to work putting in an infrastructure for
fire control and actually fighting fires
it's estimated that about half of all
the CCC labor went into fire protection
in one way or another
California was particularly aggressive
in this in fact the Ponderosa way was a
gigantic fuel brake that went from
Bakersfield to Redding it was intended
to divide the brush from the timber
permanently a kind of huge Maginot Line
and was done with CCC labor then after
world war ii and korea lots and lots of
military surplus equipment becomes
available we mechanize overnight and we
adopt again the kind of paramilitary
model
under the direction of the Forest
Service to fight fire this is a staged
photo that's actually near Mount Shasta
you suppress all all other kinds of
arguments there was a big debate in 1910
the same time that the fires are burning
that hey this whole approach is wrong we
should be emulating the American Indian
and practicing what was called light
burning and even the Secretary of the
Interior agreed but it became very
quickly politicized and you're either
with us or against us on this
the fire suppressors one so here we are
finally by 1960 basically in a cold war
on fire or what what the more eager
opponent proponents called the Red
Menace all of this was under the
direction of the u.s. Forest Service
which after 1910 acquired the authority
to establish federal state programs for
fire protection it controlled virtually
everything and in fact it was it was a
benign hegemon and fire was increasingly
becoming something that didn't belong
with average people it was becoming a
government monopoly in the name of
public safety well it couldn't survive
and part of the problem is that you took
out good fires as well as bad fires and
after a few decades it became obvious
that economically ecologically even
administrative lee this program was
insane it could not it could not persist
we couldn't keep pumping more and more
into it because it's harder and harder
to keep a lid on so by the 1960s fire
joins a lot of other developments and in
effect we can speak of a fire revolution
and part of that was the development of
a civil society no longer funded through
the Forest Service or even the feds
so the Tall Timbers research station a
private operation in Tallahassee Florida
becomes a very important megaphone for
advertising the value of fire the
necessity of it a month after their
first conference the Nature Conservancy
conducts its first prescribed burn the
Nature Conservancy now burns as much as
the National Park Service and will
probably surpass it the way the NPS is
going these days and lots even iconic
species are now identified as in need of
fire so our charismatic megafauna you
know three of our first four national
parks were all devoted to those trees
now it turns out we need to be putting
fire back in those by 1968 the National
Park Service had reformed its policy
seeking to restore fire by 1970
the u.s. Forest Service had followed
suit what happened well it was a
revolution from the top it seemed that
the torch indeed was being passed to a
new generation but then it went out
now the model was based on prescribed
burning particularly in the southeast
Florida still world center for this
Tallahassee's really the Silicon Valley
of prescribed fire if you wanted if you
want to know how to burn that's where
you go we projected that into natural
fires beginning in the Sierras some of
the tough spots and then elsewhere and
then even for fighting wildfire you were
given options hey you don't have to
throw everything but the seventh fleet
at this at this little smoke you can
back off there are other ways to do it
and we'll still call it control so all
that was in place and then it fell apart
in the 1980s there is in effect a
counter-revolution politically even in
terms of weather lots of things be happy
to talk about them later if you want but
in effect the fire revolution stalled it
wasn't enough to roll it back you
couldn't go back to impose the old order
it'd be like putting the Soviet Union
back in in place but you could prevent
it from advancing and it stalled and
that was really I think the last time we
had a window not a very large window
even if everything had been done right
we might not have been able to make but
we could have this was our last chance
to establish some reasonable anchor
points and build out from it in that
time past the revolution starts over
again change of administration's big
fires in California the South Canyon
fire 94 in Colorado burned over a fire
crew told the fire community a fire
suppression is broken we can't do this
anymore
something has got to change so it starts
up having the cold start over again
ever since then fires have gotten bigger
the costs have gotten greater the
difficulties increase becoming more
complicated
we're playing catch-up in a sense I
think is fairly pervasive in the fire
community that we're probably not going
to catch up so I think we're in the
process right now of inflecting into
what we might call the resilience model
okay it's an overused term but I think
it may be apt how do we get more good
fires how do we keep down the bad fires
we're not going to get ahead of the
problem
what kind of arrangement can we make
that will allow us to survive what's
coming at us well one way to think about
it is to realize we don't have a fire
problem we have lots of fire problems
hey break it down parse it some of some
of the issues that we face now have
actually got technical solutions I mean
we know how to keep houses from burning
we've known that for a long time we
solved that problem watching communities
hundreds of houses being taken out at a
shot
it's like watching measles or polio come
back hey we fix that why did we quit
doing all the stuff that we needed to do
and in some ways it's because we missed
defined the problem we think of it as a
wildland problem with houses instead of
as an urban problem with funny
landscaping but what's really spooky to
me anyway it's the way our fire issues
are beginning to channel all of our
other national pathologies and topics
Lantis is polarizing hey these
communities national parks wilderness
areas high protected areas they get a
lot of attention what about that broad
middle landscape it's up for grabs it's
going to burn it's going to burn under
conditions that probably none of us
would like we even now have our one
percenters the so called mega fires
actually their point one percent when
you break it down they account for about
80 to 90 percent of the costs in burned
area now we have taken out our middle
range of fires we have lots of little
fires that we catch and then we have
these giant fires that we can't do
anything about which are burning more
area than if we'd had lots of middle
fires
so we've we've perverted the whole the
whole arrangement so where are we now
well I think there were three all these
strategies are still in place sort of
historically we you know inherited but
they're still operating there's a large
crowd that wants to go back to the way
it was let's just bomb these things out
of existence let's get some really big
planes let's do a lot of Technology
let's get really serious and knock these
things out we did it before we'll do it
again they want to reassert suppression
and they want to change fire into more
of an all hazard emergency service well
there are a lot of reasons for doing
that if you're dealing with urban areas
actually this is the model of Cal Fire
which has become an urban Fire Service
out in the woods it's hard to remember
that not so many decades ago it was it
was a Land Management Agency now it's an
emergency service and that's a great
that's a great system if your primary
land uses urban sprawl it's not a great
fire system if you're trying to do
things with fire to get a lot of
ecological goods and service but that's
a very attractive political approach
it's happening around the world the u.s.
and Australia are probably the most
aggressive at resisting it at the moment
the restoration strategy is still alive
it's inspirational to many people a lot
of people are doing all they can to make
this work and their goal is to change
the context remember the way you control
fire is by controlling its setting they
want to get ahead of the problem we can
identify the strategic areas we can
harden the assets we can create more
robust landscapes we'll have to do more
than just burn we may have to do
mechanical treatments we may have to do
some herbicides we may have to do mix up
some grazing and wildlife management we
haven't even begun to think about
serious ecological engineering where's
the fire equivalent of integrated pest
management well partly because we've
defined fire as a physical problem we
take physical countermeasures so we dump
water we dump
tired we move hydrocarbons around that's
not really addressing the issue the
problem with the restoration strategy is
one of scale temporal scale geographic
scale Arizona has the largest experiment
underway for forest restoration project
for national forests relatively
homogeneous forests if you can't make it
work here you can't make it work
anywhere their goal for ten years was to
treat 50,000 acres a year half a million
acres at the end of ten years well
they're already three years behind
actual production they're now down to a
goal of thirty thousand acres a year
meanwhile in 2011 a fire burned five
hundred thirty-eight thousand acres in
three days this takes a lot of work a
lot of money a lot of political capital
a lot of social capital we're probably
going to be able to protect our sequoia
groves our municipal watersheds we can
protect our communities we're not going
to protect the larger landscape
so finally resilience and I think this
is what I sense in the fire community
now particularly the coming generation
hey it's too late too many things are
coming at us too fast we're not going to
get ahead of this problem we're going to
try to provide point protection
otherwise we're gonna back off burn out
draw boxes burn out the boxes will
rebuild landscape out of the large fires
that we've got because we're not going
to be able to get ahead of it this is
not restoration this is not moving
towards desired future conditions and
this is not even applied science as we
traditionally think of it that science
informs and management acts upon it this
is just playing catch-up so that will
come through with with with something
left at the end well all three are in
play I think of them as a kind of
rock-scissors-paper game at any one
moment one triumphs over the other and
is in turn beaten and we need them all
we need rocks to protect against bad
fires we need scissors to help promote
good fires and we need paper hay because
the ideal can be the enemy of the good
and this may and a managed wildfire as
oxymoronic as that may sound maybe what
we have to deal with it's a paradox live
with it because this is what's gone this
is what's going to happen coming up
we're gonna have to think differently
we're going to have to think outside the
fire triangle and I think the prophet
Ezekiel had it right because we shall go
out from one fire and another fire shall
devour us we're not going to solve the
fire problem we can solve parts of the
fire problem but we are always going to
have to deal with fire because it's not
just a tool it's not just an ecological
process it's also a relationship so I
spiraled down now let's let's go back
and try to end up here the long history
of fire hundreds of millions of years
natural fire patchy in the world
anthropogenic fire expands the domain of
fire enormous lee andrey codes the
patches and pulses under which it burned
and then we come to industrial fire you
can see I'm no graphic artist but trying
trying to indicate a thick landscape
because we're now taking stuff out of
the geologic past and passing it on to
the geologic future and that is changing
how fire appears on the landscape in
particular anthropogenic fire is going
and because we like nature reserves
we're having lots of wild fire returning
so we have two grand combustion realms
symbolized by the map we've got three
kinds of fire the problem for
sustainability is going to be to divide
three into two and have something left
over because if we don't we are simply
ceding the world to fuel fire ok
technology can enable and science can
inform but ultimately we make our
choices on our values how we see
ourselves in the world how do we see
fire two very different visions
the future world and fire biosphere two
completely sustainable engineered world
something we could plop down on Mars in
principle there is no place for fire in
biosphere two zero behind it the site of
candelita mountains full-throated
wildfire the aspen fire roaring over the
top this is a place that not only will
have fire but needs fire how are those
two going to be reconciled or equally to
the point what's missing in this image
and what's what's become missing in our
our narrative of fire is a middle that
shows us using fire constructively to
make a more habitable world so let's go
back as we approach the future let's go
back to the past fire as a creation of
the living world ourselves as keepers of
the torch I think we have to two big
narratives what I'll call the Promethean
narrative and this speaks of fire as a
technology fire is something rested away
from its its its site perhaps by
violence and certainly held in defiance
of the existing order this is the fire
in our machines and we need a lot less
of it the other narrative let's call it
a primeval narrative and it speaks of
fire as a companion as part of our
shared stewardship managing the planet
we are the creature who is supposed to
get fire right for the rest of creation
we need a lot more of this I
particularly like the kid well how else
is he going to learn how to burn if he
doesn't walk around carrying a fire
stick no wonder he's grinning well our
pass is a wreck
of how we have used our fire power and
our future will be a record of what
we've learned from that experience and
that's a story that yet to be written
but I think when the time comes to tell
it I'll bet we choose to do so around a
fire and with that I thank you
[Applause]
many thanks T well thank you so the
revolution from the top failed and in
the 90s you felt there was a time if
only that revolution of understanding
this more sort of organic approach to
fire if it had been in place all would
have been well how exactly would that
have been that it played out if we
hadn't lost those decades I think what
we would have had is an array of sort of
model landscapes with fire and those
would have become points of positive
infection and they would have inspired
and helped make the transition to a
better landscape instead funding was
pulled fire research nearly went nearly
folded mid 80s they were talking about
making a final stand at the Missoula
fire lab if necessary they circle their
circle there their engines and then hold
off as long as they could and I think
you also needed and political tolerance
was reduced and that was at all levels
you're going to make mistakes you know
you're doing something we don't know how
to do how do you manage wildfires and in
areas and so somebody makes a mistake
and they get slammed
mm-hm but there's no guidance well
here's what you did wrong here's it
here's how to do it right there's no
there are no rules of engagement and so
people in the ground weren't willing to
take that risk you said this early is
1910 there was a counter argument to the
fight every fire as early as you can't
Smokey the Bear and all that and all you
can stop forest fires Bambi yeah that's
the one that wheel I grew up on in the
oh my god but starting in 1910 you said
there was some awareness of how Native
Americans had basically managed
North American landscape with fire how
would how would you describe that I mean
there's a book here in California called
tending the wild yak at Anderson which
is basically how the many tribes of
California kept the entire state in
order with very very sophisticated
burning from the seasons what times what
place all of that and that stopped with
the arrival of non-indians and and then
it went away and and Kath as in a
preface one point where she's going up
on a mountain ridge I like up in the
Trinity Alps and looking out and she's
with a local tribal guy and they're
looking out at this and he says look at
it it's just wilderness now he's
disgusted so what what's your sense of
what the Indian mode at its best was and
is there any piece of that one can do
now I know of some pyromaniac Indians
would like to bring back native
California burning well I obviously we
can't go back but we can certainly learn
I think from those experiences right now
when we adopted prescribed fire as a
kind of Applied Science approach so we
would do science we would write
prescriptions we would designate a
particular place a particular time have
checklists mm-hmm that's what the
prescriptions meant and that turns out
to be a formula for failure because it's
always possible to have something stop
it you only need one thing to stop it
you're out of prescription but there's
no way to speed it up so what you need I
mean we're going more and more now to
really large landscape scale but we need
the the temporal side of that it's not
one day hey you're following the snow
the melting snows up the mountain mm-hmm
you're you're you're burning as things
are curing you're going back to the same
spot more than once this is the kind of
almost fire foraging
mm-hmm that I think characterized many
Aboriginal societies mm-hmm using fire
and that's what you need to learn from
when we had that debate and
interestingly enough British India had
that debate in the 1870s the first
question they asked they printed up all
their conference in the first forestry
conference on this topic first question
was is fire control possible and if it's
possible is it desirable Wow and right
at the start there split all the
administrators the intellectuals the
authorities the military all want fire
control because they see that as
controlling the landscape and the
population all the people on the ground
say this is crazy it's not going to work
and they predicted everything that would
go wrong so what's the vacation in India
that the Indians did their manage the
landscape with fire oh absolutely the
same as here or different oh yes Wow
it's pretty much common and you see the
same patterns in the pattern the pattern
is one of burning particularly I mean
India is perfect because you've got this
well-defined monsoon mm-hmm so so you
would burn you would start burning
little bits early in the season where
it's not going to spread you protect the
areas you most want protect it and then
you keep adding to the patches mm-hm and
then by the time the early dry lightning
storms come or the driest period you've
protected everything you want so any
fire that happens by accident or arson
or lightning isn't doing any damage
you're protecting them but denying it
fuel basically you've preemptively
burned it sort of a backfire in time
that's right
Manuel Mehta asks how are controlled
burns regulated local level state level
fed somebody in California wanted to do
a controlled burn where did he go for
information and guidance yeah good
question at all levels all kinds of
authorities are involved fire can be
damaging escape fires liability issues
are acute and not just the fire it's the
smoke so you've got a horrible air
quality San Joaquin Valley and we're
talking about burning millions of acres
in the Sierra that will then
send lots of smoke down this is going to
be a tough sell California was a leader
the century ago and light burning and
doing it we've got photos lots of stuff
what do you do today
it's tough my my best advice would be
that again to go to civil society and
there is a coalition of prescribed fire
councils and there is a prescribed fire
council for California and I would talk
to them that's a state level thing well
it's it's not it's not a state
organization it's a state level and
except for Southern California which is
a world unto itself and Northern
California chuckle says Allen the Nature
Conservancy's involved private
landowners and others are involved or
doing it and they realized that if they
just operate individually they'll all
get picked off one after another you
have you have to you have to have a
massive group to be able to be able to
counter it and they can provide
assistance they could provide help and
that's where I would go if I were
starting in California I would look to
that group first and they can provide
sort of model instructions training and
the rest so I'll tell you something I
saw in Indiana in the an area that
Nature Conservancy was responsible for
and they're they've gone so far in the
prescribed burn thing that they now have
a randomized computer that is basically
duplicating what lightning fires would
be like and so the areas that they're
burning they're burning not at the you
know the season when it is most
convenient for the people and safest all
those kind of they're doing when
lightning might have set a fire and then
they're setting it then see what happens
and what I saw there and you must have
seen this is areas where they've been
doing the prescribed burn that were just
flourishing with biodiversity and by
abundance there was all kinds of life
there next to pieces of former farmland
that have been abandoned and then either
protected or just now
use that become instantly a Midwestern
forest relatively deep offered just dark
and empty inside and you see this rich
savanna meadow where they've been
burning up to the forest and there's no
life in there and it's pretty
fascinating to see now they as they
pointed out they would like to have
Buffalo back that used to live in that
part of the country and then the
combination of grazing and burning gives
you that mosaic of grasslands Savannah
and forest that is the richest possible
environment that's true and they're in
areas that have succeeded in getting
fire back in the arguments are now about
seasonal timing about mixtures and
particularly about the wildlife and
that's a missing ingredient because
partly because foresters are still
directing the fire scene in many ways
we've gone into defining it all in terms
of fuel so it's fuel reduction it's fuel
this feel that well that's sort of
silviculture by other means I'm not I'm
not being cynical on this I think that's
something they understand it's a metric
that can be measured administrators like
it did you get did you meet your target
or not whereas most of the burning most
of the need for the burning is for
ecological reasons so you've got these
these two competing theories one is well
we'll get the fuel ripe by mechanically
thinning doing whatever else we'll use
fire as a tool to help on that and then
the ecology will sort itself out the
other approach is that well we really
need to get the ecology right and if you
get the right pattern of fire then the
fuel will will automatically adjust but
they're two very different mindsets and
they approach it in different ways and
once these fires simply as a tool and in
my mind well if it's only a tool for
reducing fuel find another tool mmm-hmm
where the real argument for fire is that
it's doing ecological work that nothing
else does so is there a trend toward
away from the strict forestry model to
more of an ecological embracing model
that includes and although some people
and other things yeah I think there is
but it's slow and if that
level the funding is all they want clear
metrics and those metrics are fuels
reduced hydrocarbons shoved around this
kind of thing and it's interesting
though that where most of the prescribed
burning in the Midwest and elsewhere is
most vigorous it's because of wildlife
mm-hmm I mean all these all these
animals that we like so much a huge
fraction of them you know they don't
live an old-growth dark mm-hmm shaded
for us right and they go extinct they
leave they leave and so that becomes a
very powerful argument you want turkeys
you want deer you want these other
animals and all the associated
butterflies and microbes and even the
Predators a tough you're gonna have to
burn to get this and you'll probably
have to combine burning with other
things it's really an interactive
technology and what's been missing out
of the the fire fuel formula is the
animals component which are very
important and I think I was at a Nature
Conservancy site in Western Kentucky
hmm and they were saying you know we
just can't get this border between the
grasses and the trees right by burning
it you know we're doing all the fuel
stuff and measuring it in the flame and
I'm thinking what's missing if there's
probably some biological agents that
would work with fire and to do that and
they're missing there are a lot of
things missing as you know out of those
systems and that's probably what what's
lacking we're working on bringing back
the passenger pigeon see usually out
here up the forest just a fire also
edible
but let's go back for for 15 years
season after season you went back to
hiding fire where were you what was
going on I was well I was at I was at
the North River grand canyon north rim
the grandkids were through the best
tomorrow I just of all places you know
it was it was great I started a few days
after I graduated from high school then
I went to the Bay Area I went to
Stanford and so I I had a dual life you
know half the air dedicated student
books and wetter and fires in the north
rim in the summer and then put all the
books aside and put on my boots pick up
a shovel and we'd go do fire you were
proud and you were fit and the u.s. knew
of what the mission was
it sounds pretty was it was when I
started at the mission was very clear it
was the last year 1967 it was the last
year the Park Service operated under the
old 10:00 a.m. policy which came from
the Forest Service announced in 1935 and
a.m. every fire would be controlled by
10:00 o'clock the next morning next
morning whether it's you know a hundred
feet away from the ranger station or 100
miles there is one single standard and
that's why you get smokejumpers that's
why you get aircraft that's why you get
but you know it's very attractive
administratively hey you either do it
you don't did you make it or if you
failed then you plan to control it by
10:00 a.m. the next day why 10 o'clock
because that's when inversions I had to
break up it takes off again and that's
what the burning period yeah so now we
have hotshot crews are they the same or
different than like you guys were doing
well we were we were a district crew we
were situated we were situated on the
rim we occasionally went out someone
someone once asked a visitor came
through saw I was wearing our fire
shirts and said hey are you guys hot
shot's and some guy piped up nowhere
longshots yeah we adopted it he became
officially the North Rim longshots right
and reviewers and others have
consistently confused that and think we
really were hotshots
we were much better because we got to
know a place and we got to know fire in
a place that's not just migrant workers
going around it's hot shots are brought
in from beginningless and gangs of them
and everything that's right interesting
but they are hot and they are pretty
capable teams as I get it they're
well-trained you know and if you've got
a going fire it's you know it's blowing
and going and you're in rough country
you want to call them in they're the
guys you want but you know is that the
way you want to manage fire on the
landscape mm-hmm I mean we're just
playing whack-a-mole with fires and
until we could have hotshots every 10
miles and we're not going to stop we're
not going to solve it so worldwide is
this a growing problem with the drying
that comes with climate change yes is it
a changed problem because of that well
it changes fire is always changing and
so fire in global change context fire it
fires at cause burning peat for
conversion in Borneo to bomb I mean it's
a huge source of greenhouse get maybe
the largest in the world right right
seed so fire is part of the problem and
the other hand drown out other climate
induced changes mean fire is a
consequence of it so we could and
everywhere it's a catalyst so it our
first burning now because they're drier
and they're burning now partly because
they're drier but they're also burning
because we've got a legacy landscapes of
fuels
we've got broken landscapes brokenly as
legacy I sort of understand we haven't
had fire in a long time so there's a lot
of fuel buildup what's a broken
landscape I just think it's one that's
no longer capable of regulating itself
it's no longer functioning
or broken by Otis I have want to know
more with that mean large version maybe
have of a natural landscape that has
well let me let me tell you where it
comes from it comes from an analogy like
lots of ideas and I bet I've watched the
dominance of the physical model mm-hmm
and you know in built landscapes fires
that's what you want and you fight it
with physical countermeasures and you
define the problem as one of an excess
of fuels excessive climate so you move
hydrocarbons around you have early
warning systems you build bunkers you
try to attack it at the source but I'm
thinking you know a lot of the issues
are really because these ecosystems are
no longer functioning they're broken by
owners if we thought about it in more
biological terms we might be thinking
about the problem is fixing those
landscapes rather than just attacking
the landscape what do you do well there
are lots of things you know you can
rearrange the fuels you don't have to
just haul them off as fuels you can you
can think about thinning you can think
about managing wildlife maybe even some
prescribed grazing here and there
selectively would be useful you can do
lots of things let's think about let's
think about making this less receptive
to the kinds of fires we don't want but
more receptive to the kinds of ones we
do and that doesn't mean nuking the
landscape you know for 300 feet around
houses or every structure it means
landscaping it means adjusting it and it
may mean let's think about using
biological means so maybe instead of
thinking about this as the mega fire is
a as the equivalent of a tsunami or a
mega drought or these kinds of large
physical climatically driven things
maybe we think about it this is more
like an outbreak of avian flu or it's
like an emergent disease how would we
think about it if that was if it was
defined in those terms we would be
taking different kinds of measures
another we've defined the problem
as a physical one maybe we should be
thinking about defining it as a more
biological one that these landscapes are
no longer functioning as they did and so
what had been a seasonal nuisance is now
mutating into something really really
rabid
okay so I've heard I hang out with other
ologist because we're working with
endangered animals mostly some
endangered plants and there's a lot of
talk in that world about the missing
megafauna the big animals of the big
predators and the big herbivores and we
you know we've almost lost the Buffalo
and but we're able to get them back
someone and they're somewhat substituted
for by free ranging cattle but there
used to be a lot more and what I'm
increasingly understanding is that North
America was like the Serengeti in terms
of the just the abundance of enormous
amazing animals camels and all sorts of
things and likewise farther north the
so-called mammoth steppe was ahead on
these very large animals which people
showed up as beers and that was the end
of the they were free launch and waited
you think big animals back as part of
the unbreaking landscape you're talking
about I think that could be it could be
part of it but that's the kind of
thinking we need because as long as we
just define it as too much fuel we're
not we're not really getting at
ecological goods and services which is
what we want and I think that's what's
missing out of our efforts to restore
these landscapes
I mean I've looked at the the target the
the thin and burn for ponderosa pine
plots outside Flagstaff Arizona a bold
experiment my hats off to him go for it
guys they have an 8 foot fence around
that to keep all the animals off because
the minute they burn it the elk are
going to be all over that and the rest
so to keep in a sense to keep the
metrics good you have to create this
artificial environment where the animals
are taken out what would be the problem
of the elk coming in well they would oh
they would eat all the
they need it all and so they would they
would upset the fire pattern because the
only way the only way to do it is to
have so much dispersed burning right at
the elk are always around you overwhelm
them otherwise they crowd in and they
double down on it you get a problem so
that's what I think I mean if I if I
were advising fire science I would say
let's have a biologically based theory
of fire to go with the physical one
because we need both Oh Arizona is doing
experiments anyway how about during this
experiment there you are you're at nurse
on a date and make it happen
I'm the only fire person at Arizona
State we're not a land-grant school I'm
a historian for heaven's sake sighs well
you know history includes the future
Alec de tanto has a question what
direction would you give a future
society with no preconceived ideas about
how to manage fire take this start-over
mode or the you know there's places in
the world
you mentioned the developing world
developing world is developing fast
they're moving out of the countryside
into the cities they are they've got an
excess of what you're calling bad fires
and they will now be in a transition as
they organize as they move from
developing to developed countries they
don't have to make the same mistakes
these developed countries do you know
what's your advice to them of how to say
India to make the transition include
fire and a wholesome way well India is a
bad example because okay shine also
influenced by worse by the Brits that
they they don't want any fire at least
in principle Mexico would be is an
interesting one okay they have actually
and they have actually now enacted at
least in law a principle for prescribed
fire so they went for a while in 1998
they had a very bad fire season a lot of
people killed a lot of a misguided aid
from the US and elsewhere to sort of
build up a fire suppression organization
so they were try that and realize this
doesn't make any sense in this country
at all and they need to adapt their
traditional agricultural burning
two different purposes and this law will
allow them to begin moving in that case
so they are actually slowly taking the
right steps we missed a great
opportunity with the breakup of the
Soviet Union and all those new countries
to give them an other model than the
Soviet one which was strictly a
paramilitary approach they had 8500
smokejumpers cross-trained 4 repellers
they used explosive cord it was just a
command and control system applied to
fire and it was it was a disaster I mean
it works all these things worked very
well for a few years and then the
blowback comes and fire is out of
control completely
so they lost it much of the world is
going the wrong way they're taking fire
and putting it into urban Greece for
example poor Greece have got so many
problems other sorts but they also took
fire away from their Forestry Service
which managed it on the land gave it
basically to urban fire services which
have no idea so they lost the
countryside which is now over growing
which is now burning and now they they
can't control it
they've it's it's gone so I think we
missed a chance to tell people what are
the right institutions mm-hmm for fire
how do you support a fire science
program and part of it is that we've
never studied that that it's never it's
never that kind of social science
history has never been considered
legitimate research topic you study fire
behavior or you study fire ecology you
do the natural science stuff that will
tell us what we need and it's not
telling us how to make it happen on the
ground so it sounds pretty bleak skin
huh
where are rays of hope if any I think I
think there are there are pockets of
hope my my hope and it may be sort of
the last refuge of if not intellectual
scoundrels others who don't wish to
despair is that I really do see a
generation change underway we've got in
the fire community people who are still
fighting stuff from the 19th
sixties I mean they're going back to
their youth and this is this is what was
it mattered to that and they're going to
fight to the bitter end they may be
retired that they organized and they're
still fighting they're still fighting it
we've got a group of people I made in my
current research and travels this stuff
doesn't matter to them they're they're
starting from a totally different set of
principles and they accept that fires
got to be in there we've got to find
some way to make it work and if we can
stay out of the way
they'll make lots of mistakes but I
think we'll be better off to what we are
now are they and I heart that knows
about each other that communicates with
each other that you know sort of is
building a fresh world or they just
young and that's their own oh they're
there for the joint fire science program
it's one of the real success stories in
federal fire was it was great at
nineteen ninety eight it's part of it
it's kind of an internal reorganization
to fire at that time and it took fire
out of the Forest Service exclusively so
the Forest Service could still do it but
there were other other points to get
involved again we're creating a kind of
civil society and a part of that they
have been creating these fire science
consortium and so now all the major
regions of the country have these and
they are becoming points of gathering so
those are good and we've also created
other civil society as coalition to
prescribed burning now probably I think
almost 50 states now have contributions
so we're creating outside the paralyzed
federal system in many ways the state
system which is simply charged with with
protection and putting fires out we're
creating an alternative society which is
seeing things differently now what what
I see potentially happened is that the
feds are not going to be able to get it
right on most of their land they're not
going to be allowed to I mean the Forest
Service is starting they have a lot of
land so if they're getting it wrong
there that's a lot of wrong yeah I I
don't think they're allowed to to do
things because we can't decide what we
want that land to be and so we're
willing to have it burn and until
the burning reaches the point that
you're really faced with solvents choice
are you really willing to split the
child mm-hmm or are you willing to
compromise its this is what's going to
happen
I see the feds however is providing
support some logistical support some
funding support most of these local
communities don't have the capacity they
need even if they get it they they need
an extra supportive equipment they need
some extra maybe legal advice creating
systems for liability they need they
need some other assistance and probably
only the feds could do that
so I see the feds making a presence
known indirectly the nature conservancy
has been fairly successful using fire
without getting sucked into the fire
fuel that having different targets being
nimble being able to to organize
clusters of people effectively the scale
is still too small but there are these
are all points of hope so I think maybe
focusing on the federal system
maybe misguiding I also well Nature
Conservancy is the largest conservation
organization in the world most trusted
in all of this they had most
science-driven they've 800 scientists or
something like that presumably other
conservation organizations or similar
organizations are emulating some of that
or they specializing often different
during their also I mean all these
groups have their own their own targets
the most effective groups for fire are
mostly wildlife groups people who are
interested turkey or certain kinds of
birds really pheasants
pheasants forevers in Nebraska
who'd a thunk it you know the loose
hills of Nebraska here they are trying
to organize the local land orders to get
some burning done before they're there
pastures and the grasslands are
completely taken over by Eastern
redcedar this horrible invasive it's a
woody kudzu right has taken over the the
Great Plains and do the burning and they
will provide burn
fully equipped they will provide
guidance they will do things so this is
an incentive to the locals it gives them
a little extra boost so those are the
groups but they need they need a
coalition of these groups to muster at
the state support so that they can get
the legislature to at least not put laws
that prohibit them from doing it
various animal specialist groups do they
connect with the other animal specialist
group of the pheasants forevers the
Ducks on wounded folks and that's but
that the wildlife the wildlife groups
are very important it's interesting the
the birders are very important in this
most of the eastern wildlife certainly
in the southeastern all the endangered
species live in fire prone areas and
encourage burning so the red cockaded
woodpecker may be the greatest source of
burning in the country right now because
it lives of the longleaf pine which has
to burn there isn't a lot of longleaf
left you burn and some of the I'll tell
you some of the best longleaf pine red
cockaded woodpecker habitat in the
country is at Eglin Air Force Base which
is the zone where they explode munitions
right and this is burned they burn it
early in the season so that the
munitions fires don't spread and the
munitions start lots of fire and there
the greater the woodpecker density is
closest to the ordnance zone the other
some of the best prairie the best
prairie in the United States is at Fort
Sill Oklahoma
of course right where it's an artillery
zone so they burn they're starting fires
year round yeah so you get a great mix
it constantly burn whenever it's ready
to burn it's burn that's some of the
best parent we got well military base is
typically a very good conservation for
rice in my experience so it sounds like
if you get the wildlife guys together
with the military guys and but there is
a kind of a accidental set of right
perspectives that I think you're
pointing out here and these are rays of
hope you
they are rays of hope the the birds and
the west coast you see go the other way
mm-hmm so the northern spotted owl
Mexicans but a talent and instrumental
in shutting down burning because some of
these sites might might get consumed
so we really have an east-west divide we
need more fire friendly animals yeah
well I think the great example here
maybe one of the spectacular success
stories in North America is Banff
National Park from Canada which became
very serious about burning the Canadian
Park Service had written into its
legislation that they would have - over
a five-year period meet the average burn
for that period so they were required by
law
the average burning sort of the natural
the natural what would happen nobody
knows what that is but they don't write
a whole lot of fire taken so they made
up a number and they're gonna try to
mean well the other thing is that there
there are almost no lightning fires
about hmm so this was all set by
indigenous peoples right so and they've
got all these charismatic creatures
they're the Grizzlies the elk the wolves
who like fire all of those live in fire
in burnt areas right none of them live
in old growth for us so if they though
the creatures are great leverage for
them
you want you want to keep Grizzlies here
you better give them some berries to eat
and you're going to get that by burning
and so they do really edgy birth
edgy brain what does that mean well I
consider I consider lighting crown fires
with at a kilometer of Banff
City pretty edgy burning lighting and
crown fires yeah they have prescribed
crown fire and crown fire cease when it
goes to the top of the tree and he
freaks out its crowned its crown for
your lives but that's because if you've
got a wind and you've got slope you know
exactly where that fire is going so you
actually have very good control over so
you want wind prescribed burning without
wind as it is well that's interesting
the wind tells you it's going to win
tell seward's guy it also disperses some
of the heat well if you're not doing
crown fires otherwise it can cook
underneath your kill trees so you want
wind and the more wind and a sense the
better you know where is he
I mean well otherwise the fires blaze
goes up the fire learn carries all the
convective heat up to the canopy and
kill the needles all right just by
scorch it doesn't have to burn them up
and you see this all the time
you see these dead these red needle
trees and burn areas well they weren't
burned out just the heat so what you
want is enough wind to help disperse the
heat and scatter it so you don't get
that effect and you get the the added
benefit you know where that fire is
going you've got good good I feel very
confident and I've got a steady wet the
problem is a steady wind that's that's
the I'm getting a sense here and and
we'll call this to stop but at this year
of talk is a work with the animals work
with the wild animals that are in some
sense fire friendly work with the wind
and you know I was hurt oh god it's
windy we're gonna burn to death no it's
it's windy and we're gonna have a burn
that we can know what it's going to do
so you've got to pick it we've got to
start thinking outside the old triangle
we had this I mentioned the wall of fire
in Arizona five hundred thirty-eight
thousand acres fine well is patchy I
mean not all of it was incinerated some
of it was skipped some of it was burned
lightly real mix I thought we missed a
terrific opportunity that fall that was
a spring fire wind driven fire that fall
if I ran the zoo I'd have been in there
burning mm-hmm because you now have well
protected sight you've got some stuff
that's burned out nothing's coming back
your this is the time to burn this is
the perfect time to burn and the next
two years I would be in burning out some
of the places that were lightly burned
but had a lot of needle cast again
because you've got to protect it the
cycle of historic cycle of fire from a
variety of ignition sources is probably
three to eight years so now five years
we haven't done anything well we're
gonna let it heal we've list one burning
cycle already mm-hmm that presented us
with an opportunity to build landscapes
out of what was a mega fire presented as
a catastrophe no this is also an
opportunity but you've got to be nimble
you've got to be able to go in you've
got to think differently than the way
we've done it you've got to be fire
foragers you've got to be seizing that
opportunity we've missed it we've missed
so many opportunities on these large
fires
they presented a landscape that we could
have built something out of the future
now it's not the design landscape
desired future conditions here's what
the science tells us here's what we'll
do we just muster the political will and
money can we do it and we move towards
that goal no this is being we're being
presented with large-scale massive
mashups and that's how you have to think
about fire management now that's how
you're going to do it Stephen I want a
book from you I think we all want a book
from you which is basically how to do
wildfire right and nobody else can write
it we want it from you thank you for
coming tonight
[Applause]
you